hello ha yes and I've got an acht a via
oh my god
and my grounder bodyguard Wow to protect
me from stray bullets so seriously I
ain't fan of the show so is my entire
family I kind of made them all watch it
so they could suffer with me um but my
question is you guys look like you have
a lot of fun on the show but if you
could play any character other than your
own regardless of gender
who would you play Monty
I love Monty I seriously do I have like
a slider stun you can say it and I'm
actually here on the line
downtown is sorry I don't out just
thinking um I love Caine III only want
to play Caine is that big-headed him yes
okay I love Caine just skip Merida I'd
play the horse cuz then I'd like survive
the longest and I can just run away
haha not the gorilla fell out there oh
yeah named Pumbaa uh Oh No Wow um I play
LexA I'm a human like number one lexif
in hell man that was mine get over it
still gonna say it so okay act shocked
me sorry I was just so nning out
thinking um I love ya I love Caine
um I don't know is that is that yeah I
would I like Kano it's like okay good
you like it's big it's just big head
yeah well now that Lindsey ruined it uh
I would I would I've always thought I
loved LexA but at the same time does he
like makeup yeah I do
by the way everyone on Twitter who
wanted me to redo my nails guess what
the chip nails are here you're just
gonna
with it so just take that and run with
it uh so Richard LexA
LexA I just think what Alicia did was
untouchable though I think she was
fantastic in it uh who would I play
funny actually I did originally edition
for Bellamy remember that joke what do
you remember that yeah he doesn't
remember that I remember that yes that
is that taping this Oh burn it burn it
give us your Bellamy Murphy I'm done
thanks very much
hi I'm Tobin Carter I'm I'm a big fan of
your show I have 40 people who have all
been told 20,000 times by me to watch it
and now they're all three seasons in so
yeah 40 um yeah I've been talking to a
lot of people um my question is what is
one of the like craziest things that
happen during your audition process for
the show I can't answer that
well allies are never audition I never
audition oh that was crazy she's that
good we didn't know oh how she was gonna
be till day one of the table script and
I was like please be good please be good
please be good yeah and obviously we
were amazingly lucky and blessed Chris I
was scary
Chris's audition was particularly good
and memorable actually he ate chips the
whole time while he was auditioning I
don't recommend that but it was very
funny well did it work it did sweet it
did for sure and Lindsey walked in and I
don't think I've been a part of it I
just I did an audition like that before
it was just like oh that's it and just
walked in like we shut it down literally
was the first day and we Shari's thanks
had you ever had that before
I don't know if it's true I mean he's
totally true and you know it I've
definitely you know I mean it was day
one maybe the second person I looked at
the casting agent and I said
we're we're done we're making the show
right now it was like we were really
busy it wasn't during the pilot it was
for episode 1 no the show episode 2 and
so yeah so there was a lot to do and it
was like your gut you got when something
she's good enough let's go yes you good
enough you guys want to put it off move
on
I feel like we're missing out that
Monte's chip eating hasn't made it into
the story are there are there any good
night ships are any prospective actors
out there if you ever have to make a
self tape I highly recommend wearing
gold hipster glasses eating tortilla
chips throughout the entire scene and
just add limbing as much as you can
was that for Jasper or was that for Mont
you know that's for Monty it was Jasper
I think auditioned for Monty - yeah for
Monty
yeah that was great there's a whole
other version of the hundred out there
yeah that would be very strange
thank you very much hey guys my name is
Lisa and I'm from Russia that's my job
and I want now to ask you to pretend to
be Jason for a second and if you could
wish for one thing to happen to your
character in the upcoming season well
hopefully seasons what would it be and
why can I just remind you he's our boss
it this feels like a trap is this a
trick yeah um this is the writers room
okay all right I'm Jason Rothenberg
right now let me think let me think
anything maybe I could have a scene
where I like laugh and smile and like
every time you want to sing a song oh no
no sir no singing no singing
I'm Jason Rothenberg here we go
no I am Here I am okay you know that guy
Ian you know we should get him to direct
an episode you know what
what do you think I think that's a good
idea why don't you direct an episode
this season okay
he's directing an episode this ah well
if I'm Jason Rothenberg then I would put
more flashbacks in yeah good love those
oh that's torture I just want a
motorcycle Oh
give Raven a motorcycle it's a brilliant
idea I've got something better for you
snog Oh not gonna take it hey what it is
um I've never shared one line with this
man over here so I'd love to have a
scene with me really you got up on that
that's my wish really yeah we discovered
that we've never we've been in a chased
him remember up the hatch but we never
agreed lines not once have we said words
to each other so how awesome on turfy
okay I'm trying to think if that's all
shot engine starts not gonna happen make
it happen J Murphy is it gonna happen
Ritchie I don't know we don't know if we
can make it we try to make it happen
kick it around see what happens in come
on yeah he's okay I did want to follow
up I just wanted to ask about flashbacks
cuz you did not that episode that was
set on the arc which was really cool to
see but was it interesting to really
make sure that all lined up correctly
and that you know kind of tracking where
each character would be are you talking
about seven yeah 313 313 I believe it
was yeah that was no I was so scared
that I would look so much older means
they out as part of that that hey the
hardest part about that episode is that
Eliza's character was in a Cell right
yes we wanted to have her come out on
the stretcher that was your yeah that
was all I had to do that day that was an
easy day work I'm sorry actually a lot
of fun though wasn't really fun to be
able to go back it was so weird putting
on the old costume I was like oh it
still fits thank God
yeah
oh yeah I did in the in the season
finale um yeah I I would love more
flashbacks I think like that would be
awesome for us so can we can we do it
well it's not gonna spoil whether we're
doing any flashback to sure but you know
when we do them it's usually to try to
like illuminate something new like it
was Raven who took the spacewalk or
Welles who was covering up for your
mother like there's usually some real
important story points so we could
certainly do it it's in our toolbox cool
nice quick wonder prom episode hmm I
wonder prom episode I'm wrong yeah I
never got to go to a prom I'd love a
problem space prom yeah they have really
happy proms on the ark that's not a
thing yeah space homecoming there was a
dance Oh Octavia yeah Tamia was around
Raven did you get a go when I wasn't
there no I was in solitary next question
please
hi I'm Joyce from Malaysia so my
question is what was the hardest scene
you've ever had to film on the show we
know sorry
um gosh um I've had a few um I like you
today I would yeah saying Unity Day
which I still even can't say in an
Australian accent it's just times in a
row Unity Day oh you know there's a lot
of outtakes of it I think they're online
um so one of the I think one of the most
challenging and I am maybe Lindsay you'd
agree was Finn's death oh yeah that was
a really really hard hard night and day
I think we we worked until 7:00 a.m.
that yeah day I was
and we were you were in Santa Monica we
were in the forest in the face and
called um the rain but loving it
obviously um that was that was that was
incredibly emotional and painful and
obviously we were saying goodbye to
Thomas McDonald who we love and and then
it's between that and Lex's death
obviously was a very very very emotional
day and yeah we both cried a lot and so
did Dean our director and you did - I
did he cried yeah you know the shows
quite physically challenging there's a
especially when it gets to December time
it gets very cold and very wet
I remember episode 213 Dean directed an
episode we were up till 6:00 in the
morning shooting and it started to rain
and we're outside that probably was the
most physically challenging I think I
think we were all in that episode and
that scene um
well and you live in Hawaii you know
yeah I used to used to Island you were
there I think you left early brother I
did no I hate money chosen also as I do
live in Hawaii yeah I am Ian for one
second just Dean's names come up a
couple times and he's an executive
producer this season and I really wanted
him to be here he's prepping episode 1
and I think he deserves a little bit of
a shout-out he's directed me not to
shout out shout out Andy white he's
really the unsung hero of the show
yes I'm too exact me I really wanted him
to but we're prepping we just start
prepping the insert well I guess he's
busy yeah I have a challenging story I'm
not sure how appropriate it is but I
must say Denny oh gosh yeah I know yeah
okay so the the episode where um Octavia
was trying to convince Lincoln to go to
Luna but he wanted to stay in Arcadia I
began the scene on my knees cleaning the
horse's hoof and we had to completely
change the camera angles constantly
because the horse kept having uh she
told us
so had to keep changing the camera
angles cuz it looked like that it was
attached to mine so that made it pretty
awkward was that really hard is that a
hard is probably an out I mean you have
photos I've seen so I then hit the with
a stick to make up way but I was
supposed to cry that's what the horse
trainer said to do is in a limit is
thick a little bit like a flick a light
flick anyway end of story
Octavia that's the best one that's all
top that one guys I don't think I'm even
gonna try don't know if I can I just
think you're just being tied up and
possessed but that isn't be heritable a
horse it's nothing now but uh yeah
Ravens uh ally possession was just was
was a riddle we were over there easy an
amazing you were so nice that was like I
have never brush watched a woman work so
tirelessly and and give zero complaints
I like I tip my hat to you for that that
was a guy but honestly I mean I had
everyone here South you you didn't you
weren't there either yeah he wasn't away
but everyone here you know they had my
back they were helping me with
everything we had to do kind of a scary
stunt and I was and I was nervous about
it but I didn't want to say anything and
Eliza stepped up for me and talked to
our director and that was that made me
feel really supported by our like by the
family so even though some of the scenes
are so brutally taxing physically and
emotionally and just like awkwardly yeah
it's so great that we have each other to
just you know yeah but laughs and you
know support us when we need falafels we
will ya eyes cry like you'll be in the
trenches but that one for me was hoof
yeah
that was the night I did a set visit to
the hundred you yeah I only person gets
interview with Lindsey because they're
like Lindsey to the bite look is not
available
literally yes Chris I I had to learn how
to drive stick for the world there's
nothing scarier than driving at night in
heavy fog with a camera like two feet
away from your Rover with someone who's
only driven stick for an hour so um that
was scary
you did it the nailed it
uh physically I'd say the hanging scene
in season one was probably I go my god
if it wasn't I don't like those ones it
wasn't like one of the best things that
I loved shooting that scene those so
much fun like anything you get to throw
your body into they kind of helps the
scene that was honestly the hardest
thing that I've had to watch on our show
period artists nice team does such a
good job at the rigging and everything
so it looks very real yeah actually
reel-to-reel yeah but a ton of fun so
hardest but also one of those fun times
I've ever had I have to ask a follow-up
on the rover just because it strikes me
that you know they all grew up in space
they they were they adapted pretty well
to driving a car should we assume that
there was some great driving stimulating
stimulating of video games on there
simulation gas they definitely had Xbox
okay and you know they also had three
months in between season ret two and
three so they learned and wife and Raven
built that car from scratch so don't
even really drive it it's the Raven Robo
you just use your mind yes like I need
somewhere to play put your hands so you
know I just think there could be a great
montage of everyone learning to drive
and crashing constant look at their
flashback Jason I think I still don't
know how to drive so maybe don't in real
life I seriously had done we need to
work on that this year let's make it a
goal okay all right next question
hello I'm Lauren from himmat my question
is so imagine there was like some
show extra radioactivity and you all got
powers what would they be what their
characters are demigod characters yeah
ah I would like to know what everyone is
thinking all the time that would be my
superpower as Ken mind-reading yeah that
would help my diploma no it's over
political [ __ ] oh Jesus
anyone else oh I would like to feel no
pain oh yeah that's a good one good one
feel no today I'd be you know like like
Wolverine right or he'll really sorry I
killed that for you Bev city lot skip it
it's cool sorry Abed I'm dealing with it
um gosh what I would love a flight no I
think I would love I'd love for clock to
be able to freeze time so she can just
think for a goddamn second about well
she's gonna do that would be mine do you
age in that time no no please it's
frozen right I get to stop bullets I get
to like do it you know that like like
Piper in Charmed remember that no that's
that's what I would do yeah I am yeah I
like her answer meet you gentlemen me
okay uh I know you won't you want to
know how he feels
well now he feels well no yeah well
that's a--that's my own guy though but I
already knows I already know that yeah I
know that's a yeah I'm gonna go with
immortality but you might already have
that some good did you say immortality
mortality that's a power kind of in a
way no yeah it is vampire yeah that was
a little vampire that was mine
you took it was it yep flight I don't
know what do you me to say no one
visited or go to fly it should be
invisible
you could have taken well I have some
other priorities focus on her
next question please hello my name is
Colette I'm from here San Diego my
question is specifically for Eliza oh
with your role as Clarke in the most
recent season what was your most fun
scene okay do you know what it was like
they actually like the most fun okay so
I think we all remember me in LA showed
you know in the bed together we could
not stop laughing like honestly it took
us so long to shoot this scene because
it was absolutely hilarious laughs up
you're giggling a lot of there was a
little bit there was a letter it was so
funny I have some hilarious selfies from
that from that day actually and I did
say that I would I would I fight with
Alicia's permission I will I will post
one of them soon um yeah no that was
just it was so much fun and we yeah it's
it's amazing that they got a shot of us
looking passionate and not like laughing
at each other thank you very much I see
some familiar faces out there there's a
lot in the mellah me oh it's a Mellark
baby I've seen you guys before yeah you
take a picture with them at WonderCon
could we hold your baby yeah okay sure
if you want to come up here and pretend
that you're Bob for a couple questions
yeah right up there makes that on um
hello who's right now oh there there we
go hi yes anyone can hold this baby any
time please hi um I'm Caitlin I'm Rob
and this is Laura Highline oh she is
she'll
I know right - young to watch with a
hundred yes so beautiful um cool nr okay
so our question was that if your
characters had the day off to save
themselves from worrying about their
impending doom what would you what would
your characters do for fun or to relax I
would lie on a beach maybe get a couple
like cocktail chill out in the Sun that
is what I would do pretty much the same
I think you know you should not anything
that landless I kind of do but no I
think I'll show you never see us like
enjoying a sunset I'll actually go hang
out on my tree I think I'd do that oh
you love that bonsai check out fathers
Octavia needs to take a shower that's
right we're gonna use that shower oh we
really need to somebody taking sure my
hair's gotten a little Oh nappy yeah
yeah anyone else um I'd get a massage
from I think Monty would find a nice
secluded space with Harper Oh
oh yeah and discuss political science
all day
I think Murphy might find a nice
secluded space by himself away from
anyone with fists and he might just lie
there and weep like good weeping he
needs a little boy the boy needs a good
cry and I think you just have a good cry
and then the next day he'd be fine he'll
feel pretty good yeah all right thanks
guys thank you
bye Laura oh you should
that's hilarious because my name is also
Laura so it's like Oh
okay hi I'm good to see you
um I've been told I'm the last question
sorry guys it's amazing now thank you uh
my question is for the ladies what does
it feel like to be some of the best most
complex female characters on television
for like you as an actor Wow oh my god
that's a great that's a great last
question yeah it is it is an absolute
honor I cannot tell you how many times I
have played the dumb blonde [ __ ] best
friend of some guy of you know that that
whole that whole character I've done
that for 15 years now and the last three
I've been able to play someone smart and
strong and responsible and and worthy
and and it honestly like it makes it
gets me emotional because it it it makes
me so happy and I love that we're in a
day and age now where women can pee the
portrayed that way yeah
and I gotta thank this guy for it yeah
oh yeah um I'm an auntie I have nieces
and nephews so I'm just happy that they
can watch TV and look up to me doing
something positive inspiring other you
know not just women but you know young
young boys as well we're just people in
general we're not you know I don't want
to name names or sale anybody down the
river but you know nowadays thanks to
social media and a lot of things I find
young girls are looking up to the wrong
kind of things oh I know is my nieces
friends or when I was like wow I was not
wearing that little of clothes at your
age so it's pretty cool that we get to
you know play warriors or really smart
mechanics or doctors and and yeah I just
we have the best job ever I'm glad you
guys like it just to extend on both
Eliza and Murray's comments
I personally am extremely grateful
because as a woman especially as a woman
of color you know it's funny how
Hollywood want to put you in a box and
that box is labeled made or that box is
labeled pregnant or that box is labeled
you know just a girlfriend or a [ __ ] and
that's so I don't wanna say demeaning
degree it's so meaning and degrading
because women are so much more than that
and you know and it's and it's not even
like Oh women are stronger these days no
women have always been strong women have
always been complex manipulation capable
and able and amazing at least at life
it's just now we finally Hollywood's
finally catching up to the norm and
waking up and I'm so grateful to be part
of a show and a network and a team of
writers in a creator that sees the value
in that and sees how important it is to
portray that representation for women
in the world and the mass media because
media touches us all that and that's
what we need we need to we need to see
we need to see examples of empowerment
because when we see that it no longer
doesn't seem abnormal but it seems like
that's the norm to have the armament and
that's extremely honored injury that a
good note to end on these guys are about
to start making 100 season four which is
they doing midseason on the CW so please
thank everyone here from thank you bye
you